[Music]
when was the first time
i became triple world chess champion
do you think you have the answer then go
ahead and send it to ulda
at playmagnet.com and you can join in
our christmas competition
[Music]
good evening my name is uh sebastian
i'm an employee at play magnus and today
i'll show you how to deal with magnus at
10 years old
so let's click on a little fella
there we go so we're not nine years but
we will move on to uh
ten there we go ten years and um
two months is uh what i'll go for today
uh china played a milk junior in ultra
tournaments uh whatever
he probably he's very strong at 10
actually
he is good do not underestimate him
under any circumstance whatsoever he is
not to be taken lightly so we will go
for one e4 by test there we go
e4 he plays c5 so he's already
very very sharp so against actually so i
played c3
against magnus i will play this sneaky
move
bishop e2 one of my favorites certainly
a rare breed
the point is to just play f3 and then
after d5 i can play d3 in the end game
after d takes c4d takes e4 is actually
quite good
but anyway i'll play d3 here bishop g7
um all right i'll just develop i guess
c3 is also logical to take away the
dd4 square i want to do that and then he
plays bishop h6 magnus what are you
doing
haven't you learned that you should not
move the same piece twice in the opening
that is one of the key rules oh that is
what he wanted to do all right
i'll just play g3 protect the pawn can't
see anything else a5
that doesn't really do much i will i
actually want to play a4 because now i
get a grip on b5 so i can play knight a3
and i'll get my knight to b5
he plays bishop f8 magnus magnus what
are you doing man
magnus nine he he knew better
queen d7 you're doing great am i
thank you so much i'll just castle i
mean i haven't done anything special
bishop g7 magnus you've moved that
bishop
five times now oh wow
okay knight c4 it is
uh attack b6 queen d7 i'll just keep
pushing my pawns in
the center here and that's d4 now that
i've developed every single piece i'm
going to push in the center
replace knight f6 uh
can i play d5 now to push away tonight
definitely can yes we can so e5 is
desirable but then he takes and then he
takes on d5
you do not want to let that happen so
queen c2 we protect the pawn very simple
now let's get our rooks into the game
get one we have e5 coming
he takes on f e4 and i blundered
oh that's a bad wonder
that is a bad number sebastian if you
lose this game
you're not worthy you're going to be
making a video on magnus 10 and you
blunder this tactic his point is of
course that when i take it as bishop of
5 my queen is trapped
that was crazy so rick d1 was terrible i
should have played bishop d3 or
something
okay uh yes not h4 because then i can
push f5 in the next
move while he does it he pushes f5
instead
not very good okay
so i can take on e4 but then i'll get
the worst pawn structure ever i do not
want
that to happen should be seven
he's protecting the e4 pawn indirectly
because if i take on e4 and takes
the pawn a4 will be hanging all right
magnus
and i can't really play b3 because then
the pawn on c3 is hanging
these pieces are not well developed but
i lost a very vital pawn upon e4
let me be a bit tricky and i'll play g4
making use of the fact that if it takes
the knight will be hanging
uh g5 he doesn't have the f6 square any
longer b5
wow wow wow
hmm and why shouldn't i take one f6
right now so what i take on f6 he takes
on c4 i take 27 it takes back with the
queen
i would say i have a bit of compensation
done
i can go back with bishop e2 and attack
the pawn on c4
yeah i don't see anything bad with that
takes
bishop e2 attack the pawn
then rook a1 protect and then i'll take
so we won back the pawn it's a step in
the right direction
we had such a good start i mean we have
a dream position
out of the opening
96 and i'll play rookie one here
yeah he wants to do that and that's very
clever because my my pawn on d5
is very weak very weak
all right i'll play knight h4 i gotta
start attacking the queen g2
maybe it's not so dangerous once again
i'll protect the pawn
queen f6 watch out oh he i blundered
again
unbelievable knight of three
queen takes
oh okay now my i'm in huge
huge trouble i do not want to trade
queen cell
but ah this is very very very bad
i have to start attacking so kg1 oh
rook g1 there we go
i think my attack here is significant uh
yeah bishop c1 and bishop e2 is my plan
so he can play knight c3 if he wants to
but i do not really care
i'll take and then i'll take back
and i bishop b2 next it's extremely
dangerous for black
look at it his pieces are not in play i
think that is a huge
huge that has a huge significance here
so if i can turn this around that would
be good i have knight g5
right yeah i do okay knight g5
so you can't take because then i would
have had a queen h3 and queen h8 and
queen g7 rookie one
if killing effect deadly effect
okay so knight e6
i have something here queen h3 yes
queen of eight and then i have queen c3
okay that's easy
queen f8 and queen c3
and that should be enough right
pretty pretty good thank you so queen f6
king e8 because if king g8 i take on g6
with checkmate
this is rough this is rough um
queen f6 king eight will keep one there
should be six probably
that one i can take rook takes knight x
green takes king g8 bishop f6 king c7
queen h7 is probably better
i think queen 87
it looks very dangerous but he escapes
if if he's
man if he manages to get to d8 and
he can just move the knight and all of a
sudden i don't do not really have an
attack
uh so i should queen h7 king e8 queen
takes g6 probably and just grab as many
pawns as i can i think that's the best
way to go
so that was the best move very nice i'll
take the pawn
definitely think i have to then i'll
take this one too
so at least i get a lot of pawns for the
deficit
okay queen g6 i don't think this is even
magnus
yeah this is definitely not even d6
bishop c's
a d6 queen e4 that's a draw
we need four queen e3 that's a draw
that's queen f3
too many checks so that's his threat
here
if not if he didn't have that threat it
would have been completely lost for
for him what a complicated position
uh i think i have to check again
then queen h8 maybe that works
yes because i get i would have gotten
d6 with check and now rookie one
this is this is over isn't it
maybe it's not queen e5 i'm not gonna
trade queens
yeah this is completely winning looks
like a fair fight magnus
oh
wait what i don't even know
jakes yeah bishop c6 bishop d5 i thought
oh i'm still down material oh
i got a piece but i'm still down
material that's why it's not winning
i got it it takes
ooh it's a bit scary now for me i have
to be very careful
okay e7 here
i blundered so many things this game and
i'm still doing pretty okay
queen d5 is what i want to do but then
he has queen d6
maybe queen d6 quintex f5
it's another pawn i do know that this is
worse for for black
for humans but
i think he's he's just very tricky he's
very very tricky
e7 is a possible move but again it takes
queenie's b8 king f7 there's nothing
i could take another pawn on f4 but i do
not want to do that
i'll go for this
yeah that was a good move
and now i can play rook d1
rookie one queen e7 he protects
everything
that bugs me which piece can i now
improve
in the attack i can improve the bishop
on b2 slightly uh i guess but
but not really there's not really a way
to get through
he's protecting every square
what a mess what a mess you've been
playing for like
12 minutes that's unbelievable
all right bishop a3 is a possible move
but rook c7 i don't see it i don't see
it
help me guys help me
because after our e7 eric takes rookie
one
but that there's no threat that's the
problem
and he's threatening some stuff
uh bishop e5 i guess is tempting
just put the bishop on a good square c4
that's a bizarre move i'll take
then rook b1 that's what he wanted to do
all along
but now i have this right king d8 i mean
this is
this is crazy bishop c7
takes queen d5 it's not winning
yeah that's winning right
that takes now uh what's the material
now
um rook so if i play rook d1 he takes on
e6 because there's no rook e one
uh queen takes a5
then i rookie one so then he'll take on
c4
because there's still no way to get what
a position queen e5
is a move he has queen a8
king g1 queen a7
king g2 queen a8
king f2 king at queen is 7 queen of king
f3 can i do that
let's not no
he doesn't have it what is his next move
it's queen takes e6 right
so rook b6 is a good move i will
guess
is it half or is does this work
you're on a roll there we go rook b6 was
a really good move
i'm pretty sure yeah okay this has to be
made
if this is not made nothing will ever be
made but not only that i have a past
pawn he has to watch out for
so it's winning for me now i have queen
g6 and e1
queen e8 i mean
sorry
e8 rook c1 king g2 queen c2
yeah it's uh it's too risky
he resigns okay nice
very good that was a mess uh certainly a
very tricky
tricky uh he plays battling the opening
uh so i would i would assume that this
is uh
where you have to beat him make sure
that you watch out for any tactics
i went i blundered so many tactics in
this game but i still won
luckily but that was pretty bad and i
take c4 was
uh i mean my position is so good there
even the e4 was maybe not necessary
because i
i lose control on the e4 square it
probably would have been better to push
g4 f5 or something
because that's what you usually do in
the closed sicilian but at least it was
not
enough to take down magnus 10 what a
game guys
what a game
[Music]
you